Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Bedirhan Cinar
Ever wonder where most of the food
you eat every day comes from?
Well, about 60% of the food you eat
is carbohydrates.
As you can probably tell from its name,
carbohydrates contain carbon,
hydrogen,
and oxygen.
But where do these atoms originally come from
and how do they join together
to make delicious foods like fruits and pasta?
It actually all starts with the air
you are exhaling this very minute,
specifically the carbon dioxide molecules.
Plants are going to breath in
this very same carbon dioxide
through pores in their skin, called stomata.
Plants drink in water from their roots
to get the needed oxygen and hydrogen atoms,
and their electrons,
in order to build carbohydrates.
What is that thing?
Well, that's a special plant organelle
inside the leaves of plants
called a chloroplast.
It's green beceause of a special light-absorbing pigment
called chlorophyll.
Each leaf has about 44,000 cells
and every cell can have anywhere
between 20 to 100 chloroplasts.
That's up to 4,400,000 chloroplasts!
By now, you've probably guessed
that we're talking about the process of photosynthesis
and you might be wondering
when the sun is going to make its entrance.
Let's go back to that original molecule of water.
The plant has to split this molecule of water
so it can get electrons from it.
But, the plant can't pull that water apart by itself.
It needs help from the high-energy rays of the sun.
So now that the chloroplast has all the building blocks
- carbon, hydrogen, oxygen, and electrons -
it can use them to go through
the rest of the steps of photosynthesis
to transform that original carbon dioxide gas
into a simple carbohydrate called glucose,
C-6-H-12-O-6.
That little glucose molecule then helps to build
bigger and better carbohydrates
like cellulose.
Cellulose is a type of carbohydrate found in plants
that our body cannot break down.
We call it fiber
and we eat it in vegetables like lettuce,
broccoli,
and celery.
Plants use cellulose to keep themselves strong.
The plant could also turn that glucose into starch,
a large molecule that stores energy for the plant.
We love eating starch from plants like potatoes,
corn,
and rice.
So you see, when you eat plants,
we're actually benefiting from photosynthesis.
The plant makes things like starch,
which we eat
and then break back down into glucose,
the first form the plant made.
Then, the mitochondria in our cells,
powered by the oxygen we breath,
can turn glucose into pure energy molecules
called ATP.
ATP powers all work done
by each and every one of your cells,
things like communication,
movement,
and transport.
But why do we have to turn that glucose into ATP?
Well, think of it like this.
You're excited to start your summer job
at the local ice cream stand,
but your boss has just told you
that she is going to pay you in ice cream cones.
What are you going to be able to do
with those ice cream cones?
Nothing,
which is why you kindly asked to be paid in dollars.
ATP is just like dollars.
It is the currency that all cells of life use
while glucose is,
well, kind of like ice cream.
Even plants have mitochondria in their cells
to break down the glucose they make into ATP.
So as you can see,
humans and plants are intricately connected.
The air we breath out
is used by plants to make the carbohydrates
we enjoy so much.
And, in the process,
they are releasing the very same oxygen molecules
we need to breath in
in order that our mitochondria can break down
our delicous carbohydrate meal.